tu sais bien que j'ai promis à ta mère
que tu utiliserais ce matériel seulement
quand la nou est présent ça peut être
super dangereux oui je sais que c'est
dangereux imagine que la police te les
confisquer ou bien que tu les perdue
hein j'ai pas perdu le costume tu as un
costume depuis quand tu as un costume je
sais très bien me débrouiller tout seul
papa crois-moi j'ai l'habitude depuis le
temps
désolé papa c'est parce que je voulais
dire ça va je comprends je me dis juste
que tu devrais avoir une vie normale
papa un gars en costume d'abeille a
tenté de me tuer dans ma chambre quand
j'avais 6 ans j'ai jamais eu une vie
normale
un peu de musique
le bébé de Hulk attends je rêve ou
t'écoute ton bouquin
non non
je crois qu'il y a un problème avec ce
bouton ça s'éteint après
un vrai heureux de rencontrer un
laveur doué de parole
tu es un homme intéressant
Scotland
les doigts OK
je suis un Avengers
est-ce que je ne t'aurais pas déjà tué
quoi
on finit par tous vous confondre
ce n'est pas toi celui avec le marteau
ça c'est Thor
on nous confond tout le temps on a un
peu taillé pareil vous êtes qui vous
êtes un homme un homme qui a perdu
beaucoup de temps tout comme toi
et là dessus nous pouvons nous entraider
alors comme ça tu étudies le royaume
quantique
pourquoi tu ne m'as pas demandé j'ai
essayé d'apporter le sujet maman à
plusieurs reprises à chaque fois tu
refuses d'en parler cassis a fait preuve
de curiosité et nous l'avons légèrement
guidé sauf que nous ne sommes pas en
train de parler de fourmis en
tu sais quel danger représente cette
dimension on le sait tous maintenant
personne n'attention d'aller s'y
promener c'est tout l'intérêt de cet
appareil c'est un genre de satellite
pour l'espace lointain ou les océans
mais
version quantique
tout ce qu'il nous faut c'est une carte
et après ça on pourra explorer le
royaume quantique de fond en comble sans
avoir à s'y rendre ta fille entièrement
conçue à télescope Hubble de type
subatomique dans la cave de ses
grands-parents
t'imagines si j'avais eu un appareil de
ce genre là quand tu as disparu
j'aurais pu te retrouver